I lost my parents
that pain
made me who I am
I spent a lifetime trying to right the
wrongs of the past
as if fighting crime would bring my
parents back
you actually did it okay so the
internet's just been hit with a brand
new trailer for The Flash and throughout
this video we're gonna be breaking down
the Easter eggs hidden details and
things you missed in it this won't be a
Beat by beat thing of what happens in
the teaser as it does couple up things
we've seen in the trailers before with a
couple of different shots and things to
flesh out what's happening therefore I
kind of want to go through all the
elements of it and explain exactly what
I think is happening in the movie I also
want to talk about some of the plot
leaks and cameos that are apparently
going to feature in the film but I'll be
serving that for the super spoiler
section come the end of the video The
Flash is also screening at cinemacon so
I'm hoping at some point we'll hear more
about the movie which will of course
keep you updated on if you stay locked
to the channel make sure you subscribe
for that and also please hit the Thumbs
Up Button if you enjoy the breakdown the
film will Loosely be adapting the
graphic novel Flashpoint created by Jeff
Johns and Andy cubit in the comics
there's some more gay the DC Universe is
soft reset and a similar things
happening here with the movie heralding
in James Gunn's DCU and the books so
Barry Allen waking up to find that the
world around him had vastly changed and
along with his mother now being alive
there was no more Justice League Bruce
Wayne also wasn't alive and instead
Thomas Wayne had taken up the mantle of
Batman after his son was shot in the
alley more that had become the Joker and
both their mascara and Atlantis were at
war with one another flash ended up
teaming up with Batman and together the
pair went on the search for superman in
order to stop the war between the two
Nations destroying the entire planet now
in this Dimension it seemed like there
was no Blue Boy Scout but they
discovered that he'd actually crash
landed on the planet and that the
government had kept him a secret rather
than Landing in Kansas super ship had
shot down a metropolis and since then
he'd been kept in a bunker seeing
nothing but Redstone energy this adult
has powers made him completely weak and
therefore he wasn't the person that we
knew in the main timeline now why am I
telling you all of this well the movie
is clearly taking certain elements of
this basic outline in order to create
its storyline we clearly have Barry
going back in time his mother still
being alive there being an alternate
version of Batman and all this stuff
with super girl yeah by the looks of it
she will be the one who's being held by
the government and we do see her
confined to her cell looking
malnourished you also see her suit
crumbled up on the ground at one point
and it's possible that this is the same
person who crawled out of the urban pod
that we saw the start of Man of Steel
and for this movie it looks like they've
changed things up to Russia as the
prison garments we see her wearing have
the language on it in the comic supes is
just known by the name subject one and
here it looks like he's being kept at an
Arctic Outpost in overalls which is why
they've locked her up and thrown away
the key similar to soups in the comics
the powers are given to her by the Sun
and this enrichens the kryptonian's
physiology so they have strength speed
and stamina it also allows them to get
the other abilities that the kryptonians
have but being kept away from it drains
them of their powers Krypton actually
orbited a red Sun and this is why it was
chosen as a way to keep the kryptonians
grounded now judging by the way that
Supergirl appears in the trailer I'm
guessing that a similar thing happens to
the way it does in the source material
with Barry and bats rescuing her he
completely cuts through the forces much
like what Supergirl does and I think
it's going to be a big scene that
introduces her in the film now in the
comics the group were also joined by
Cyborg and we know from behind the
scenes stuff that Ray Fisher was
supposed to be in the film there's been
a lot of things going on with this
treatment on the Justice League set by
Josh swedenwich is now public knowledge
and because of all of this Fisher won't
be in the film it's a lot of things to
go into that we don't really have time
to but but I think it's a shame because
Cyborg's a pretty big part of the
original story and I'm guessing most of
his lines and so on will be given in the
second Barry I can't imagine what you've
been through
I love you monkey you lost both parents
in one day
I went back in time to save my parents
but instead
I completely broke the universe
if you went back and changed the past
this world must die
to change the future
do you know what the symbol stands for
means hope right
I will help you fight God
the second Barry looks like he's
possibly going to be ripping on the
reverse flash and we know that there is
gonna be an evil alternate Barry Allen
who shows up in the movie The funkos
have already spoiled it it wasn't made
they've spoiled that there's a dark
flash in the film and there are several
shots in the teaser where you can make
out the evil Speedster and the comics
Barry discover that the reverse flash
had followed him into this timeline and
the villain left a slight trace of
himself in some CCTV footage though he
could move faster than the camera could
ever pick up he did this deliberately
because his ego had to let Barry know
that he was there amongst them he showed
up at the end when the world was going
to hell but it was at this point that it
was revealed it wasn't him behind it
instead he showed that Barry had doomed
the world in trying to save his mother
and you simply there to just rub it in
his face at his attempted act at heroism
had been something selfish this
ultimately destroyed that entire reality
and thus he showed up to boast and
basically be like what a [__] chump
you are now whether the second Barry
becomes a minor might be a misdirect but
either way they do use this color yellow
throughout the trailers you might notice
that the Barry from the main timeline is
always framed in blue and this carries
across from the scenes with his mother
dying the outside of his house and even
the color of the world around him when
he Taps into the speed force his
lightning bolts are blue and this color
has clearly been picked to show this is
our Barry now on the opposite side of
this we have the second one who has
everything appearing in yellow again we
see this reflected in his child at home
clothing headphones and also the
lightning when he Taps into the speed
force the only comics when Barry broke
the timeline the version he woke up
being didn't have his powers this is
because when his mother died it didn't
lead to the butterfly effect of him
receiving them in a lab accident when he
was older thus he had to recreate it
with Batman away mana and after an
initial failure this eventually led to
him getting his powers back oh it seems
like they've Switched at the powerless
storyline to the second Barry and at
some point we see the pair in a lab with
lightning passing through one into the
other only Comics they have a moment
where Barry was on top of Wayne Manor
waiting for a lightning bolt to hit we
have a shot where the batwings up in the
clouds and then a lightning bolt
descends down from a rope on it which
may then hit Barry and pass from one
into the other might be a Batwing might
be a batarang might just be a kite and
they could be doing a sort of Benjamin
Franklin slash Back to the Future nod
with that on top of this there's also a
shot of Supergirl flying a bit in the
clouds with Barry so she's potentially
charging up after one of the power-up
attempts fails I'm guessing that this is
how Barry 2 gets his abilities and then
he'll end up getting an old Batman
costume spray painting it red and then
filing down the horns on the top of the
cowl this has been shown on some of the
funkos action figures and posters and
even when they do the boot to boot shot
you can notice that this is the one from
Batman Returns now it is possible that
the timeline here also gives away what's
actually going on with this version of
the character potentially when Barry
time travels he goes back to the point
before he got his powers and this would
roughly be the at 2013. now why could it
end up being this date well we have a
strong emphasis on zard who returns for
the film rather than being from an
alternate timeline this may be the
version that was first encountered in
Man of Steel we see his message to Earth
from the You are not alone I am here
with you seen and also the desert one
that pops up in that film we also get
the world engine and Zod at one point
pops a blade out of his Gauntlet like
the one he used to kill Jurell they will
be seeing a lot of things pop up from
that movie but obviously Henry's version
isn't there because this alternate
timeline has Supergirl kinda reminds me
that this movie is relying very heavily
on the Sonata verse for stuff when DC
have sort of treated it like the cousin
you pretend you don't know because
they're a [__] idiot go back to the
loft Benjamin my mates are coming round
anyway we get a recreation of the scene
in the desert when Zod demanded that
kalal be handed over however it looks
like Barry and Batman's plan isn't to
give Supergirl over as they know it just
leads to the world engine attack
therefore I'm guessing they refuse and
this causes Zod to lash out and attack
the military now potentially we are
getting multiple timelines merged
together with Barry Shenanigans and this
is how we can have Michael Keaton's
Batman and Michael Shannon's sword there
are rumors we're also getting other
cameos as well which we'll talk more
about in that super spoiler sections
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts now we are also getting
at least two versions of Batman in the
film The Best of these has been
Affleck's version and this will likely
be his last time in the caping cowl and
I know that's being said about the actor
numerous times here but but since his
Cameo is now being cut from Aquaman 2
I'm guessing that this is the last last
last time now the suit he'll be donning
is a new gray and blue one and this is
very similar to how it appears in some
of the comics it's the first time it's
been done in live action though and it
actually shows that they can pull this
look off my guess is that his appearance
probably opens the movie and it looks
like he in Flash are both working
together in daylight to stop an attack
on a hospital at one point we see the
Earth cracking at one and if you look
closely you'll notice a sign that shows
this is connected to Martha Wayne it
seems like a massive Chase with Bruce
dropping down out of the Flying Fox
Airship that appeared in the movie
Justice League think it's that one don't
know if they're going with a smaller
version but yeah it is called Flying Fox
so let's not split hair so you you've
been a bit of a [__] if you do that
made now we know that we will get him
appearing with his mask off as well and
Barry can be seen saying that he could
fix things whilst Bruce argues he could
destroy them you might notice that
Barry's wearing a [__] and tie along
with a waistcoat which he also wears
when he's on the phone on his finger we
can see the flash ring that houses his
suit which we too have had shots of when
this opens up anyway I'm guessing that
Ben's Bruce tells him to proceed with
caution and this is due to the
ramifications that it could have on the
time stream you have to remember that
this version of Bruce actually met Barry
for the first time in the Batcave and
that was due to that Barry traveling
back in time he of course came from The
Nightmare timeline which Bruce has of
course dreamed about so he may be wary
about him messing with things it's a
shame Warner Brothers can't learn that
lesson either but Barry tries to turn
back the clock to have the life he
should have had with his mother we do
see a family photo at one point and this
Echoes the one that Michael Keaton's
Bruce also touches if you look at his
fingers you'll notice that they're all
bruised up but I don't think that this
is from fighting we've seen the other
wide shots of this scene with Bruce from
behind and you can tell that the
character has long hair showing that
he's probably been out of it for a long
time when he gets back in the suit his
hair gets cut short and this sort of
follows The Dark Knight Returns in that
we had an elderly Bruce who retired from
being Batman and finding himself drawn
back into it he had grown a mustache but
he subconsciously ended up cutting this
and this is when he decided to put the
cape and Cal back on I think a similar
thing might happen here with his whitish
shot potentially confirming that Bruce
is now retired now touching this photo
also seemingly opens up the bat cave
having a photo of his parents being one
opens the doorway up to it brings a lot
with it as Bruce has to see them every
time he touches it Bruce made a promise
on their graves that he make it so no
one would ever have to go through what
he did and he's very much reminding
himself of this every time he opens the
door up now inside of it we've already
seen that there are several other bat
seats this includes one that appears to
have guns in it which could be a Batman
year to reference or it may be a call
back to how he was in the 30s when he'd
just go around shooting people and we
also have a bad suit with a damaged bat
symbol on it and this is how it appears
at the end of the 1989 movie there's
another gray and blue one and also an
underwater one alongside what thinks the
Batman Returns suit and over this we
have a suit with goggles on it which
looks like it might be this timeline's
version of The Nightmare suit anyway the
bat cave itself also has a couple of
things in it that could show timelines
merging we know this one has a waterfall
in it which feels like it's pulled out
of the Nolan verse rather than being
part of the kitten Universe either way
in here we have a Batwing which is
riffing on the 89 version and also the
return of the iconic Anton first
Batmobile this car still looks
incredible and I'm so glad to see
returning once more in the DC Universe
Batman is breaking at us all batsuit as
well and we get this iconic line you are
yeah
I'm Batman
my name is you can see the lights
flickering in and out and symbolically
this is showing that he's a bit Rusty
I've also got another Funko from this
movie of Batman that's got him in the
suit bust up really badly so he might
potentially see him coming close to
death at some point and it'll be
interesting to see how he's utilized in
the film in the comics this was of
course Thomas Wayne number four Barry
returned home he ended up giving him a
letter to deliver to his son he can't
really do that here because it's Bruce
and an alternate Bruce I don't think
that Barry will even be returning to
that timeline with Affleck in it either
way seeing them both in the same film is
something that's gonna be really cool
and obviously that's definitely the
major selling point of this movie you
want to get nuts
let's get nuts
I have to undo what I did
these scars we have
make us who we are I'm not about to go
back and fix them
no that's your tragedy to find you
check it out
no matter what we do
we're not going to be able to fix this
no
nobody dies
you're strapped to your parachutes Hey
where's yours
now other little Easter eggs include
Barry's room which has a Pacific Rim and
I am Legend poster in it both are Warner
Brothers properties with a ladder also
featuring a Batman v Superman poster so
like when people watch these movies does
it have the poster in it because how
would they know about Batman's
anyway we also see Wayne Manor and the
back computer looking exactly like how
they did in the 1989 film they've even
got that old Tech like a record player
there and the Batwing hanging up which
then descends like a bat dropping out of
a cave Michael Keaton says you want to
get nuts let's get nut KP nuts sponsor
in the channel make sure you get them
now and yeah that of course pulls from
the first film when he said it to Jack
Nicholson's joker now the Easter eggs
include zod's henchmen jumping up to the
Batwing which looks exactly like how it
did when he did that in Man of Steel he
smashes the glass but whereas he ripped
the guy's head off in that Batman
instead Dives out and then Glides down
we also close out with a shot of the
Batwing against the moon and this is
another nod to the Tim Burton movie when
he did that in the film now that wraps
up the trailer and you know what I'm
gonna say it I'm gonna say it hype might
be blind to me but I think that's one of
the best trailers that I've ever seen it
completely nailed the tone of how I
think this movie should be it feels Epic
from the off and yeah there's just so
many elements in it that really feel
like they're gonna knock it out Arc we
of course haven't seen the movie but
judging by this it's gonna be the best
DC movie since the Dark Knight
so that wraps up the trailer and I'm
guessing from now on we'll just be
getting TV spots and variations of
what's been shown with a couple of extra
things I am wondering if they're gonna
Shazam to it and blow their load by
showing the cameos in the trailers but
there are some really interesting ones I
want to talk about on the plot League
section of the video huge heavy spot
that's coming up now now so be careful
and a huge heavy spoilers for that so if
you don't want to know anything then I
highly suggest you turn off now if
you've enjoyed the video please hit the
thumbs up button on the way out and I'll
see you next time take care peace okay
so if you checked out our last trailer
breakdown then you know we're talking
about there being a rumored Batman
appearing at the end of the film there
was lots of things going on with it with
a report saying that it could be
Christian Bale Val Kilmer or George
Clooney well things have actually been
well down now and apparently Clooney's
version will pop up at the end with it
being played off as a joke that shows
Flash control travel to any Universe I
always thought Clooney was a recast of
the kilma vision which was a recast of
the Keaton version because they had the
same backstory Robin Commissioner Gordon
Alfred and all everything but I brought
that up on the last video and people
kicked off saying actually Clooney's
another version of the Batman that was
completely different which I don't know
if that's teenagers retroactively
inventing the Multiverse for Ola films
because it's not how I remember but here
we are anyway that's gonna be the end of
the film and my time to shine hello has
also report that there's going to be
another big cameo in it I'm not sure
exactly when this happens but it has
been said that Nicholas Cage yes
Nicholas Cage will be popping up as a
version of Superman in the film cages of
course castes him for the ill-fated
Timber and Superman lives and if you
haven't seen the documentary in the film
then I highly recommend you check it out
because it's [__] wild and I'm
guessing that at some point flash will
run through the time stream and pass by
some at Chelsea's alternate realities
and references to other movies but we're
gonna have to see anyway that wraps up
the video video and of course let me
know your thoughts in the trailer and
what you want to see in the movie we are
running competition right now giving
away the quantumania steel Buck to three
subscribers on the 15th of May and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the teaser repeat the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
save that to you then message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers good smells to
watch then make sure you check out one
of our breakdowns on screen right now
which will be going over a lot of things
that you definitely want to see like if
you're like me you like what I'm talking
about yeah well we all love these nerdy
things so there's something on screen
right now for you so head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video love you Paul
I'll see you next time take care peace